each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
thank you all for coming this evening my
name is Duncan wats I'm a principal
researcher here and one of the thirteen
founding members of the Microsoft
Research New York lab i'm standing in
tonight for a Dave Pennock our assistant
lab manager who was supposed to deliver
these remarks unfortunately Dave's
father passed away on tuesday morning so
he's obviously not able to be with us
but our thoughts are definitely with him
and his family as you know tonight is
the first instance of what we hope will
become a vibrant seminar series bringing
together the premier data science
research institutions in New York the
Columbia data science institute Cornell
Tech NYU data science and cusp and of
course our own lab MSO New York as you
are also aware despite the numerous
common interest that we in the New York
data science research community share
opportunities to interact across
institutional boundaries are regrettably
infrequent and as a result we have a
tendency to remain in our own silos
potentially missing out on valuable
conversations and even collaborations
with our peers and other locations the
primary purpose of this seminar series
is to help break down these barriers by
bringing all of us together on a
semi-regular basis to learn about each
other's work and also get to know each
other socially correspondingly the
structure of these evenings will be
deliberately informal the intent is to
start the evening off with a short 30 to
45 minute technical talk and then devote
the bulk of the evening to mingling over
wine and cheese outside there to begin
with the series will be held here at MSR
New York if only so we can give our
lovely but somewhat underutilize public
space a proper workout but over time we
hope that the location will migrate to
venues at Columbia Cornell and nyu given
that this is the first event and that we
are all still getting to know one
another the technical component will be
a little bit different rather than a
single speaker we will have in addition
to my remarks brief overview of the
other three participating institutions
more name on will speak about Cornell
Tech Tony Jabara will speak about
Columbia data science and young
we'll speak about NYU data science
following these remarks Jennifer Shays
the director of the MSO New York and
also MSR New England labs will then
moderate a short panel session on the
general topic of the evolving New York
data science community before I hand
over the lectern two more Tony and yawn
let me say a few quick words about MSO
New York it has now been almost two
years since thirteen of us founded this
lab under Jennifer's leadership in fact
we are hosting our two-year anniversary
celebration on May 5th and although in
some respects that time seems to have
flown by it is also amazing how much has
happened in that period both in MSR and
also in new york city from the labs
perspective it was a pretty chaotic
start to begin to be honest with you in
part because of the turmoil at yahoo
that we left behind in part because we
were all trying to learn how to be a
part of a new organization at the same
time and in part because we had no
physical home of our own two years later
i think it's safe to say that we all
feel very much at home both in our new
and quite beautiful physical space and
also at microsoft and we are making
exciting progress on several important
fronts aside from our founding team we
have added several new members some from
other MSR labs and others recruited from
prominent universities enhancing both
our diversity and also our quality we
have a vibrant visitors program
comprising both short and long term
visitors who inject continual variety
and outside perspectives into our
routines and discussions we have a large
and active intern program that allows us
to supervise and collaborate with
outstanding graduate students from the
top universities across the country and
indeed the world we have continued to
generate world-class research in machine
learning computational social science
and algorithmic economics including most
recently accounting for eight out of the
80 accepted papers to this year's ACM
conference on economics and computation
we have also begun to have an impact
internally at Microsoft with our
researchers actively reaching out to
product teams across the company and
initiating increasingly ambitious
projects
we'll be talking a lot more about these
accomplishments on May 5th and I hope
that some of you can join us again then
be given tonight's purpose I'd like to
emphasize that the past two years have
also witnessed a series of exciting
developments across the broader New York
science data science of the broader New
York data science scene Cornell Tech for
example which was announced only months
before our founding is now up and
running in temporary space just a couple
of blocks west of here in the Google
building and construction on their
eventual rusev elf Island campus is I
believe imminent almost contemporaneous
with our founding and while you
announced the launch of cusp the Center
for Urban science and progress and just
months later Columbia announced the
creation of its Institute for data
sciences and engineering and pleased to
welcome Steve Coonan here tonight and
Cathy McGowan who are leading both those
institutions shortly after that and why
you separately announced its own Center
for data science and then in 2013 along
with UC Berkeley and University of
Washington launched a five-year
initiative in data science funded by the
moor and sloan foundations and finally
over the same period the tech startup
scene in New York has really exploded
with companies like BuzzFeed at sea for
foursquare and hundreds of others
gaining increasing prominence and even
beginning to shift the economic center
of gravity in New York away from its
historical location in finance looking
back on all these developments it now
seems almost pre cient that two years
ago Microsoft decided to open a data
science oriented lab in New York maybe
it was just lucky but regardless of
whether we or not we anticipated that
now is an extremely exciting time to be
in this particular community in this
particular city I hope this seminar
series will help the different centers
of excellence for data science interact
and learn from each other and in so
doing help New York to become a world
center of excellence for research and
technology before closing I would like
to say a couple more things first I want
to thank the data science seminar
organizing committee led by our own
Jaron budak and joined by more name on
representing Cornell Tech Chris Wiggins
representing Columbia and young McCune
representing my you
for organizing the program this evening
and Jeff Jericho Irene money re de luna
and and Jensen for providing the
technical catering and logistical
support and finally on behalf of the
entire msi New York lab I would like to
publicly congratulate our boss Jennifer
chase on her recent election to the
american academy of arts and sciences my
only surprise my only surprise of this
announcement is that she wasn't a member
already but she assures me that she's
happy to be a member of the class of
2014 on the grounds that she's now
classmates with al pacino
congratulations Jennifer so I wasn't
sure what to expect really because I was
asked to give a technical talk and then
I was told it was five minutes and and
so and then I just realized that you
know I should really talk about the
center of data science at NYU so so I
have sort of a boring talk about the CD
s but you know we can we can talk about
this at the you know after in front of
drinks i think i'd be more useful in the
meantime I have a demo that runs just
about five minutes so I'm gonna do that
all right so let's see all right so I
got you're not seeing anything on the
screen yet but you will in just a second
this is just to show you a bunch of
stuff that are going on in my lab at NYU
in collaboration with work Fergus as
well as you know I'm where your second
hat which I'm actually hiding behind my
back right now the second had being
director of AI research at Facebook and
one of the things that we've been
working on over the last you know couple
years for some of you ten years for some
of us at NYU and I'm sorry to say 25
years for me is deep longing and deep
longing in the last year or two I'm sure
many of you are aware where this is that
becoming extremely successful and
another thing I'm sorry to say is that
this will
lot of cycles that are being burned to
run deep learning algorithms these days
by Microsoft Facebook Google and it's
gonna is going to get a lot worse over
the next few years to the point of you
know we're going to be boiling the
oceans or consuming a few nuclear power
plants just to run commercial net so
here is a comment from that this one
runs on the laptop and you can recognize
stuff that I point the camera at so
let's see if it recognizes this notebook
computer that's a notebook computer so
each recognition here takes about five
billion multiplied ads to do this
recognition let's see if it works on
microphone and identified of Jack water
bottle yeah it doesn't like this kind of
microphone does it how about this guy
that's a great either um all right how
about this what is this that's a loop
yeah close enough about that do you talk
Clark yeah okay digital clock digital
watch it's good enough I'm gonna use
your shoes okay don't move loafer
folding chair okay cuz enough laptop no
that's not a laptop it's a folding chair
I don't think you knows about stools but
dang table okay put her mother's yeah
close enough yeah so okay now we haven't
totally sold vision yet but but we're
we're getting pretty close remote
control so this thing knows about the
1000 image so called imagenet category
and I lost my cell phone does anyone
have a cell phone how about this da
meter well close it on yeah the monitor
so you get an idea of what I'm not sure
if it knows about this at all lamp
spotlight okay spotlight not bad so you
know we have it it's not like vision is
completely solved but it's getting
pretty close and things are getting
better and better by the day as our
machines become more powerful and as our
datasets become bigger and bigger and
companies like Microsoft Google and
Facebook are furiously collecting data
to improve the performance of the system
and you know boiling the oceans doing it
so here is another version of this demo
which this one I can train to recognize
any object i point it a point to so
let's say I pointed to Duncan here so
Duncan you're going to be a okay so i
click on the learn button a couple times
and now it recognizes Duncan and if I
point in someplace else it's not Duncan
and you look like Duncan okay right so I
guess Duncan is that so it's not
actually recognizing people it's more
like it's doing a gif start recognition
since I use you guys I'm going to use
myself as well alright but what this
shows is that was just a few example
training examples which are the the
numbers indicated here you can train the
system to recognize new categories with
you know relatively you know relatively
good robustness to variations of arias
kinds in size position and etc so that's
sort of the power of deep running if you
want and this only became practically
the last couple years has been widely
deployed among other other people by by
Microsoft for speech recognition as well
as by Google and and for image
recognition by just about every web
company now so it's taken the world of
computer vision by storm and and it's
been it's been it's been quite a ride
and there's a lot of interesting things
to explore here so one of the things
that happen over the last three years is
that deep learning pretty much
revolutionized speech recognition at
least the acoustic modeling part of
speech recognition deep learning also
revolutionized computer vision a lot of
computer vision papers now are just
about the only browning nobody talks
about design features anymore and it's
very likely that the next frontier for
the planning is going to be natural
language processing and language
modeling a lot of people are working on
this some of us are thinking of
essentially embedding all entities that
we're looking at images text speech in
the common space actually following an
inspiration that was originally proposed
by Leon go to and and I think there's a
lot of very promising avenues there so
here you go for a completely content
last five minute technical talk and I
thank you very much for your attention
alright so I'll use my five minutes to
talk a little bit about myself and my
research touch about things that we do
in touch on the thinker's we go to
Cornell Tech and talk a little bit about
the challenges that I see for us in New
York in data science so it's gonna take
five minutes i promise you like it takes
okay all right six minutes none if
anything more just shoot me so I call
myself an information scientist my
background my PhD in computer science I
do a lot of data work in particular
around social media my research the last
few years looked at social media data
and we did social media data science
from the first date of social media and
from slightly before there was data
science so the method that I use range
from those that we are we require deep
engagement with individual users so we
do it Naga fees we do interview
sometimes social science style two
methods that require shallow connections
with lots of Amazon servers you know
when we have computational methods at
scale hence I call this information
science in particular the this year in
the last few years we've been interested
in social media applications for cities
for urban areas social media is public
mostly public mostly available in a semi
proprietary manner a lot of times
location-aware and offers a lot of
information for us to process and help
us understand cities so what can we do
here are just a couple of examples very
briefly especially in New York there is
a constant stream real-time flow of
social media information about the city
so we build the system called City beat
that is kind of a dashboard for
journalists and city staff to understand
in real time what is happening in New
York this system coughs called barks
lead which we just started working on is
working with the New York City
Department of Parks and Recreation to
use the social media shared a
neyo parks to help them improve their
operations and briefly mention my
startup which we have related data
analysis work to make sense of the world
stories based on the social media that
shared from them we want to make those
stories accessible and not just a huge
huge amounts of content without slapped
on a page and those system that I talked
about are rooted in user centered design
and computational methods like a nepean
machine learning and in HCI in
human-computer interaction but other
than the systems work i also do work
that is more theoretical in nature
perhaps in area that sometimes called or
overlap with computational social
science so in one study we have you know
we know as you know from the media
everyone is asking whether social media
is making us lonely this is not
interesting our interesting question is
you know we know that people are using
social media to tell us about to
communicate their emotional experiences
what can we learn from the communication
about the experience of loneliness and
about how that experience plays out and
relates to social media so doing this
kind of work obviously requires
knowledge from a lot of different
disciplines including sociology
psychology communication and many others
so those of you who know me know that
I'm not the expert in any of them so
that's our first challenge that becomes
how do we how do we acquire those
expertise around those disciplines that
we want to work on so one thing that
we're doing at Cornell Tech what we have
the Jacobs Institute which is a Cornell
Technion collaboration the activity in
the Jacobs Institute is organized around
hubs and the hubs are you know we don't
have a data science program we have
programs that are centered around hubs
where we also teach data science so
Hobbs right now our connective media
healthier life and built environments
and we want to make sure that those hubs
provide help us bring people from
different disciplines to reason about
these areas
so the main challenge that we have I
argue is not data is the people and the
people related challenges for data
science are numerous first the ethics of
data science we all came up with those
questions not what we can do with what
we should do the second is data
measurement how do we reason about the
data that's available versus the date
that we need to solve the problems that
we want to address modeling which we
already started tackling but you know
I've shown us how something like Google
Flu Trends turned from the poster child
of data science to the Titanic of big
data very quickly that was all about
modeling obviously we have the challenge
of interpretation and particularly we
have the challenge of mission we have
Jeff Hamburg Becker that famously said
that the greatest minds of our
generation are getting people to click
on ads we need to make sure that this
doesn't happen to us here in New York so
we went to we need to use data to solve
the problems that matter and that I
think will be our greatest challenge and
that's particularly why I'm excited to
do this to have you all here in this
room it to do the same New York because
we can do it we're not in the valley
we're embedded in a non-techie culture
we have many different disciplines
represented even in this room and
together we can focus on the application
the ideas that matter and make them move
forward I think we also have the
advantage of being one short subway ride
away from each other so let's get data
science right thank
but I was told to keep my talk as short
as possible I'll be talking about
learning from large-scale mobile phone
data sets so I'll be focusing on the
data rather the algorithms and I'm at
Columbia University and we have an
interesting new initiative that started
in 2012 called the Institute for data
sciences and engineering we are let's
say required by NYC EDC to hire many
faculty and these faculty will populate
six different centers looking at data
science for health smart cities finance
security new media and foundations of
data science so please come talk to
kathy lee director myself after the talk
about this institute i'll be focusing on
some data that i'm very excited about
large-scale mobile phone data i started
a company in 06 called sense networks
which was looking at app data and call
detail records from large phone
companies to see how people move around
the city and how they use their phones
to communicate and trying to model that
for some interesting social and
entrepreneurial applications one
application is basically looking at how
people flow in a city if you build the
markov model of how people go from one
place to another you can embed the
resulting directed graph and then start
color recording places that attract
similar plate a similar people and so if
you go here you might also want to go
there and we can do the septum
recommendations just by looking at flow
you can also do things that are more
specific on each user you can try to
model each individual's user and their
behavior history by looking at the types
of places they visit for every week our
we look at what types of activities are
you doing are you in cafes or
restaurants and we build these matrices
that describe each user and then we can
say how similar is one user another just
by computing the Euclidean distance
between any of these two matrices that
summarize them so if they are spending
their Thursday afternoons and cafes they
might line up very similarly and so we
did this and then we connected the
networks we connected the data into a
network by minimizing these euclidean
distance ISM you were able to form
little facebook like networks from
people's mobile phone data by saying oh
you overlapped a lot with this other
person so you should be connected to
them in our model we can do things like
label you then if we have this type of
net
and say okay here are the people that
were parents in our data can we
propagate their labels to other people
and predict that they're going to be
parents even if they didn't reveal that
about themselves so we started labeling
and doing head of the machine learning
approach of diffusing labels on this
graph and that basically is called
semi-supervised learning and it
performed pretty well from just a few
thousand labeled people we were able to
do things like predict the people were
parents we were able to do gender
prediction if they were single or not
there were students or not by looking at
these networks we formed and it's much
better than random obviously not perfect
but we were able to get some interesting
labels by building these graphs but then
we were recently curious about why do we
use a Euclidean distance and saying if
you co-locate with someone then you're
going to be connected to them clearly if
you collocate with me at home then
you're much more likely to be like me
but if you co-locate with me in a subway
station that shouldn't count as much so
we shouldn't just look at total
colocation we should see which places
matter more which places matter less and
so this led us to look at this problem
called the freshman problem which is if
you only know features about people can
you predict how they were coming they
were going to connect let's say after
the first year at school so this is why
they're called freshmen and we have X
which is features about a bunch of
people and then at the end of the year
we see a matrix of who connected to whom
can we learn how to predict a from X and
the way we decided to do that was we
decided to see which which attributes
matter more than others so let's say we
have some friends here this is their
their matrix of connectivity a and here
are some height and weight attributes
we'd like to predict on these new people
how are they going to be friends by
saying well does height matter more than
wait can we compute distances more let's
say for one feature than another to get
a better network at the end and so we
looked at various applications like
Facebook and I predict who's going to be
friends by figuring out which features
in your User Profile matter more we also
looked at Wikipedia datasets Foursquare
data sets and telco data sets and I'll
give a couple of quick examples as I'm
running low on time but the idea is not
to just connect people by Euclidean
distance but to learn a matrix M which
figure is that which distance is matter
more than
this is called the Mahalanobis distance
and so here's an optimization we solve
which basically says if you are
connected to someone then I want to
change distances so that you're closer
in some other space to them and so I'm
pulling and pushing distances to make
people that are friends closer and
people there aren't friends further
apart we solve this using stochastic sub
gradient descent we get some interesting
lift curves for example over here we get
the ROC curve outperforming other
techniques at reconstructing the
Wikipedia hyperlink structure from the
wikipedia word counts and so we've seen
some nice improvements on Wikipedia
network reconstruction on Facebook
Network reconstruction and on foursquare
and just a quick example on foursquare
datasets we looked at four different
schools and it turns out for example at
Columbia it matters what year you're in
for your friendship connectivity at MIT
really matters our dorm you're in for
your friendship connectivity that's the
attribute that matters more at Harvard
your status matters more for determining
your friendships and then in on the
mobile phone data what we did was we
said which locations matter more for
making people call each other and
connect through phone calls and so over
here is just the locations in the city
by how frequently they're visited and
over here we see which distances matter
in colocation land and so it turns out
to co-locate over here you're more lucky
to call someone then if you co located
let's say in the darker areas and so now
we're able to predict phone call
patterns from colocation patterns this
is preliminary results but again the key
idea is to look at mobile and social
data and to see how behaviors and
attributes I'll predict social link
formation and then our social links help
us predict attributes behavior and
behavior contagion as well thank
so thank all of you for for being here
we have all men speakers I didn't even
realize that so right now but thank
goodness a woman is running the show
okay well thank you so much for being
here I'm really thrilled that we're
bringing all of these great great places
together we called this the data science
seminar and I think you know big data
was was a terrible phrase and I think
data sciences is now now becoming too
much of a buzzword as as as well so more
is calling it information science but i
was wondering for for each of you how do
you how do you define the boundaries of
data science or if that's too hard a
task can you give me one example of a
data science data science project or
problem that would not have been
possible let's say five years ago that
you think is going to be transformative
over the next five years five to ten
years Tony I'll go first I like Chris
Wiggins's interpretation of data science
he has a really great Venn diagram
picture which says that it's an
intersection of computation statistics
and actually domain expertise and oh so
you stole it from someone okay drew
Conway so I didn't follow the links but
I think that's a good that's a good
interpretation I think that's a little
different from what that's a
machine-learning let's say embodies
which is the intersection of computation
of Statistics data science is really
also working with a lot of domain
experts to really figure out what the
important problems are and to also
understand their data sets more closely
rather than just you know faster
algorithm
and better generalization guarantees so
I mean I like that picture and i'll make
sure to say drew conway next time sorry
ah so yeah so i don't i don't have a
definition of data science other than
say or the shortest perhaps description
is anything that has to do with the
extraction of knowledge from data
perhaps with the help of machines or
math i would call data science and
particularly if it has applications to
the science society business health etc
you know the I like the term data
science compared to say machine learning
or statistics or even computational
statistics in a sense that is very
inclusive if you say machine learning
the citations we left out and the people
who think doing application feel left
out if you say you can say statistics to
computer scientists say well what about
computation and and and but if you say
data science it's kind of a neutral
ground and it's sort of mooring screws
inclusive I wouldn't call it the
intersection of any of those feels more
the union of course there are boundaries
somewhere but but to some extent data
science is really finding the boundaries
between between computer science
statistics and application areas you
know I knew going to ask that so just
ask the internet and that's what the
internet
ah so I think there's a work to be done
finish your is this is just yeah it's
awful actually it's awful Wow we all
have a lot of Education to do Chris
wants to say something ah yes right
don't be the show for the tape right
yeah when you give us some data fine do
a controlled experiment you know physics
is and right right there yeah i was
gonna sound pretty sure finish of
physics is not like teenage sex but but
i think we have a little of a red
herring in the science which brings back
obviously all of us heard these computer
science of science and why is the
science and the same question has to be
told for data sciences to catch your
name we don't know if it's a science or
not in the sense that we're not testing
about letting apart assists and so forth
but it is not always what we also do
that but I it does to me just tell the
story of how data became both prevalent
and important and requires us to come up
with a new set of tools to understand
and reason about it okay so on the flip
side which more actually also brought up
in his talk you know we all know that
there are ethical questions they're all
kinds of questions around privacy on our
panel here I think we have people who
more focus on the benefits of data
science than on the costs or possible
costs of data science but I wonder how
you view
who your role as data scientists and how
much you feel that part of that role is
defining the ethical boundaries both in
a philosophical sense and in a technical
sense to how do you try to technically
address some of those issues taking a
risk here so data science of course is
is very dangerous in many ways because
there is all kinds of issues but you
know the privacy invasion and and data
flying around all kinds of people by
companies that they have no relationship
with so you know there's a lot of people
who use services like like Microsoft
Google and Facebook where the company
you interact with has a face and has a
relationship with you provides you with
a way of controlling the information
they have on you but there's a lot of
companies as well that actually collect
your data without you knowing it and
sorry to say includes yours but with
that but but not dr. seward's I mean
this includes lots of other companies
that show you ads and stuff like that
with whom you have essentially no
relationship and that's certainly a
major problem that needs to be used to
be addressed there's a second issue
which is that data science is on a
collision course with AI so people
forgot about AI for a few years of you
that's decades and now I is coming back
as because people are gonna have the
idea that the progress of computer
technology and developed availability of
data makes a I a kind of a kosher
subject to walk on again and and you
know AI will be used for data science
there's no question and and people are
scared about AI as well so if you merge
those two things and you start talking
to people we have tons of data about you
and we're going to apply AI systems on
this you know it's kind of scary and we
have to sort of you know figure I had to
do this properly without without abuse
so I think there are a few things we can
do one is to engage with lawmakers and
policymakers
because we understand what can be done
and they don't understand what can be
done so that's that's something that we
need to do the second is to engage with
the critical thinkers and I know you
guys are actually doing it well and
Cambridge in here like so research I
don't know if Microsoft as a whole
that's the same thing but it's easy for
us to do it especially in New York so
that's that's great news the third is to
consider and highlight those issues in
our work so the two systems that I
showed you or did I showed screenshot
off for City bitten and Parks be both
have significant biased issues because
in city be you'll see mostly Manhattan
is represented in all the other boroughs
because they don't produce social media
data they disappear parksley the same
thing you know be very easy to create a
system that sends all the park
maintenance people to Central Park and
morningside park and maybe Washington
Square and nobody will ever show up in
in the bronx so we need to think about
and highlight those issues and
technologies that we create this one um
yep i agree i think we also need to as
data scientists work with people that
are on the privacy and on the legal side
of things so i've been collaborating
with lawyers in maryland we published an
article at the NYU Law Review on the
privacy issues behind location data I
think it's only by continuing to do this
science and working with other
researchers and publishing all the
results that you know eventually things
will change if we don't actually
spearhead these efforts are going to be
done internally in places that aren't
interested in publication done our
research centers that aren't
collaborative so I think we need to keep
things going rather than slow things
down because that's what prevents I
think people who aren't planning on
doing this in the name of science from
moving ahead of us don't you both in the
lawyers now we're all doomed no I don't
I don't think we're doomed actually I
know I really think that we should be
engaging more with the lawyers I mean
they are the lawyers the legislators
they are going to write the laws and so
we had better be working with them and
making sure that they are as well
informed as they can be they also like
to to cite research they like to sight
precedents and I'll
we produce those that research and those
precedents you know they're going to
pull anecdotes out of the air and
legislate by anecdote instead of by
science and research so it's assented
the lawyers with whom you work didn't
mind you're collecting all this phone
data so we don't collect the data it's
running behind a firewall at the
telephone so it's never exiting and we
give him the algorithms they run the
data okay so this was also mentioned it
was mentioned by Duncan and buy more and
others are so what do you think that we
can do in in New York to to to make data
science different from the valley
different from what might happen
otherwise how can we take the engagement
of a you know of a vibrant city with
this data science being done by people
who are who are inhabitants of a place
that looks like much of the future of
the world will look to make data science
better than it would otherwise have been
my van Hutton locker or Dean likes to
say that New York is great because for
every topic X there are you know not
there's a critical mass of people that
care about X and I think that's in New
York right that's that's true for
academia as well I think that's why
especially since I don't think anywhere
else in the world right now we're going
to have such concentration of people
interested in this topic in a very
strong academic environment that has so
many other fields not to mention our
other industries the fashion industry
the finest industry the media industry
they're all here so I think that's where
we have an advantage we are sitting with
we're co-located with you know not only
we see in this community by yourself
with the techies but we also call it a
co-located with other significant
industries that have interesting
questions and have interesting ideas
ently and Facebook so Microsoft did not
say that you heard where that came from
so I don't I don't think we should
define did a science set in New York or
in this in this area by by contrast with
what goes on in the valley it's
different by nature but because of the
high concentration of people because of
I sensed a little bit more openness so
there's a lot of things that goes on in
the value that you never hear about
because it's done in small startups that
you know may or may not succeed that
don't want to talk too much about what
they do whereas here there's a bit more
of a kind of a you know infrastructure
tissue substrate of sort of academic
research you know including at places
like Microsoft and you know soon
Facebook and you know NYU Columbia
Cornell and and that creates enough
communication forms like this one where
where people exchange ideas which I
don't think goes on in a very nearly as
nearly as much so that's one big
difference it's nice to see also that
there is a pretty vibrant scene of
startup companies you know in within 10
blocks of here mostly south of here but
also West and and and the the diversity
of companies I have activities in the
area I think contributes to this
particularly media and pharma and things
like that so you know I think yep Chris
Chris and I were on a on a panel
recently talking about you know what's
happening in New York into the science
and I think there is it's very fertile
ground and and and it's been growing in
the last two years an amazing speed who
would have thought two years ago you
know we have imagined the kind of state
that we are in now that assigns New
Yorker all the things that are happening
this is going to attract a lot of
top-level people working in our fields
we were going to want to work in New
York just because
all the buzz that's that's happening
here Tony to you I mean out again I I
totally agree I think New York is a very
interdisciplinary place and that's a
very important thing if you're doing
data science you want to work with as
many different types of data as possible
so I'm excited that I can see data from
finance from from health from new media
from social networks the whole kind of
variety of it and also new york city
itself has a great initiative partly
from the previous mirror but also from
this mayor to open up a lot of new york
city you know city urban data out to
researchers so we actually got from the
Taxi and Limousine Commission lots of
data about GPS locations of taxis and
that's I think you need a visionary kind
of city and a visionary mayor to make
that happen and I think New York has
been spearheading that and really
helping create these data sets for
people to work with and to model New
York as a data science problem great
well thank you i actually think that the
main purpose of these these evenings is
for us to be able to talk to each other
to get together as yon was saying this
it may be more than anything else what
separates us from the valley that we can
all just you know walk over or you know
hop on a subway and be in the same place
at the same time so i really want to
thank the three of you and i want to
thank everybody who did walk or hop on a
subway and and come here and we have
some food for you and please enjoy the
food and enjoy each other thank you